Speaker 1: There is an absolutely brutal new poll
in which Donald Trump is losing to Ron DeSantis
by 13 in the 2024 Republican primary. Let's talk
about it. But wait, what? You like trust polls,
man or what? Remember that moment from my
interview with Patrick about David in Florida a
couple of weeks ago? Well, listen, I mean, let's
talk about it, right? When we look at polls,
there are three important questions that we ask.
Is the pollster highly rated and historically
reliable? That's an important question. Second
question, is this one poll dramatically different
than every other poll? If you have 20 polls. 19
say one thing and one says something else. We
would want to understand why that is. And is there
something in particular about the subject matter
or the timing that makes polling on a particular
issue inherently unreliable? So it's not about
pollster quality, it's just about this is a really
hard thing or it's a really hard time to be asking
people about this subject matter. So let's ask
that question. Okay. A new Monmouth poll has
Donald Trump losing to Ron DeSantis, who is not
even running yet by 13 points in a hypothetical
Republican primary. That's 53 for DeSantis
to 40 for Trump. Now, that is a hypothetical
head to head. If you end up having Nikki Haley
run, she's expected to announce soon. If you've
got Mike Pompeo, Mike Pence, maybe other people
named Mike, or maybe some people not named Mike,
you are going to have different numbers. This is a
hypothetical head to head. Now, let's run through
our questions. Is Monmouth a good pollster? The
answer is yes. Monmouth is an A-rated pollster by
FiveThirtyEight. Even morning consult, which
is often used by corporate media. It's only
a B rated pollster YouGov Yahoo poll, which is
very much used as well, is a B-plus. So, yes,
our first question, Monmouth is a good pollster.
Is this poll an outlier compared to others?
In a sense, it is. Okay. And so we can look at
Fivethirtyeight's recent Republican primary polls
and the results are sort of off the map, not after
the results are all over the map. And so depending
on where you look, there's a primary poll from
The Economist from a few days ago. That one has
Trump plus ten. But there's a lot of undecideds
there. You look at a YouGov poll, it has Trump
up two in Trump versus DeSantis. You look at a
morning consult poll from about a week ago, and
that one has Trump plus 18. So in a sense, yes,
the Monmouth poll is a little bit of an outlier,
although you can find polling here that does have
DeSantis leading. There's a YouGov Yahoo News poll
which has De Santos plus four When it's asked in
a different way without other candidates head to
head. So the general answer is this an outlier is
when the polling is Trump versus DeSantis only it
does seem to be pretty good for Ron DeSantis
when the polling includes other candidates
or it doesn't force an answer and lets you put
I don't know, haven't decided yet or whatever,
then it seems to be better for Donald Trump. And
then we get to the third question I mentioned. Is
this something we can even really get good data
on in February of the year before the election?
Yes and no. You know, valuable polling data.
Without a clear field. Unclear about whether
Trump is going to get indicted. Unclear what Joe
Biden's next two years are going to look like
and what Republicans are going to run on and what
voters are going to want. There is a limit to how
valuable today's polling data is. It doesn't
mean the polling is inaccurate based on what
Republican voters are saying right now. It's a
broader question, which is does this type of poll,
what is it, nine plus 12, 21 months before an
election? Well, and in this particular case, more
like 17 months before the primary is going to be
of some limited value. What this polling will do
is it will brutally trigger Donald Trump and
possibly explode this feud, civil war that is
building between Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis.
And that's what we're going to talk about next.